ja hat mich keine propheten kräfte
eingesetzt ja oder doch durch die wand
muss es kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video gespielt heute eine
runde jump liege meine favoriten
spielmodus und mit dabei ist logo und
zwar nicht und zwar nicht irgendwie
sondern diesen gerade in globus live
stream und wir nehmen gerade in seinem
live stream auf weil er crazy ist ganz
gut gemeint das machen nicht so jo ok
gut spannende geschichte
ja man löst direkt das du dir einen
krank die halle auch alle leute glaube
ich richtig gefesselt zu hause hat man
alle leute gefesselt wie er den führer
hus ich mag die ganze zeit zurück auch
dass das mal an die box zurück dass das
sind das ist wie ein bäcker zu sein
du wachst zurück und man alle weg aber
offenbar nicht so klug wollte etwas
anderes wegwerfen
egal dann spielt im finale ohne hass
gegen nicht den stempel weinmeister das
so oder so schon wieder verloren
ich glaube auch ne also du mit nickname
cheating hätte ich heute gelegt als logo
49 ist schon ist von der hübschen muss
ich sagen so weit passt das ja ganz gut
diese pyramide ist ganz entspannt
eigentlich warum pyramide 8 ein bisschen
ganz vorne
ich würde mir hat die ganze zeit ein
bisschen zurück gekommen das macht mich
schon traurig das ist natürlich kaka man
kann es natürlich auch nichts dafür
dieses problems and you cannot es soll
will vielleicht effekt ist das ja genau
das was ich machen muss so alles bei als
begeisterter livestream einfach immer in
live streams aufnehmen ich kann einfach
nicht mehr so oft aufnehmen das muss
live sein
das muss einfach in einer bedeutung
immer live sein darf man man man
sie liegen diese weise von diesem
einsatz
we love und so dieses lied von rtl
we love you i love to entertain you oder
jetzt ist der spruch wer von prosieben
manchmal dieses leben das dann da in der
werbung läuft kurz gesagt bekomme ich
denn bei dem saturn ring weiter keine
ahnung
da musst du das ist die pyramide da
musst du in den mittelrhein ok
geländetauglich warschau freund t shirt
park alter dem elektro aber es ging
es ging es geht immer weiter im leben
vergisst es nie ja ich war nie auf zu
laufen
das ist wichtig auch bei jappy klubs
nicht stehen bleiben auch wenn du mal
hin fällt auch wenn du mal runter fällt
in den wald und eigentlich stirbst du
wirst immer zurück geortet so ist es
offen möchten dem fest immer zurück
gepostet
merkt ihr das ja ich weiß ich ich gehe
zum beispiel morgens in die schule und
dann gehe ich meistens in 20 minuten
früher los weil ich immer zurück geboxt
hat auch auf dem schulweg ein bisschen
zurück ja das ist so schlimm financial
ein bisschen zurückgeblieben
ich hab gemerkt dass ich gar nicht schön
gemachter projiziert dieser hedgefonds
zu vermietenden den schäden machen ich
habe angst die aufnahme ab kantate ich
traue meiner entweder nicht die kag die
ganze zeit ab alter machen später lieber
nicht an und jetzt das reicht aber ich
bin ich gerade mal bei 1 modul 5 jahre
und du gewinnst das gleich genau okay
ich bin hier erstmal vor dem sprung
lässt so schwierig dass mein absoluter
herzsprung also das mit abstand
schwierigste glaube ich das ist dieser
ewig eine milliarde schoss den sprung
da muss man einfach doppelsprung auf die
äußerste kannte machen um den zu
schaffen so der vierten station
hier habe ich aber echt ein bisschen
probleme welche gern mal überholt war
auch gestern meinen so ich leg einfach
krass liegt 150 blogger vorsprung dann
auf einmal kommt irgendwie keine ahnung
eisdiele oder so und denkt sich jolo und
macht den sprung einfach im ersten
anlauf für den ich sechs sieben acht
anläufe gebraucht habe jetzt aber kommt
irgendwie leute habt ihr irgendein trick
wie man den sprung besser machen kann
schreibt mit dem man die kommentare
ich schaffte sporen einfach aber ich
fall fast runter und lauf überlaufe
vertrügen her wo ich noch ein kleines
bisschen länger warten
ich hab ihn geschafft ich habe jetzt den
nächsten checkpoint so schöner ist dass
dieser sprung der so richtig weit ist
dann ist das so ein gerader strich wurde
draußen ja in einer kiste ist ja
wirklich schweren der ist richtig brutal
ich hab gerade echt echt lange gebraucht
und dann gibt's halt leute die halte
diese ganzen jobs deutlich langsamer
machen als ich irgendwie warum auch
immer ich habe dicke vorspann denkt dann
schaffen die aber diesen ein sprung an
dem ich komplett verzweifle einfach auf
den ersten versuch schaffte es auf
anhieb und ich hab mir so hat der
volkschor in 2d bald alles davor war
einfach so an das statement der sommer
ja kommen
geben wir dem ein bisschen vorsprung der
freut sich in seinen streams denke an
sich und da ein alter arme dann welche
mit den weg so ok läuft du alter ort
zurückgebracht
bei diesem etwas längeren paco ihre ist
ein problem runter geglitten schade so
ich bin dann soweit okay ich ja auch
fast da gewesen ich hätte nur ich das
eis paar kugel muss ich achte ich muss
darauf 8 ist kein anderer im parcours
schafft kann ihn nicht bus fahren weil
er es auch beim rasieren von 97 97 alter
das heißt eher wirren der wird er wird
mir gut oder knapp 8000 jahren wird er
geboren so da hey ich bin ein prophet
aus dem jahre 9000 junge logische
leitwolf gucken wollen den alter okay da
merke ich mal einfach ich machen double
kill und dann sind auf einfache sind
nochmal zwei leute mit ran da kann ich
nichts machen wenn ich das hier noch mal
kommt so nicht auf mich ich bin
unschuldig
glaub mir so hat das oberste us an der
der prophet aus der zukunft weg vom
future the future award eine eisenkette
will ich ganz gerne helfen
ich habe auch ein reißen wie einfach
immer 3 wird auf einem haufen sind aber
krieg krieg rücktritt du bist doch einer
down ok alter diese double kills diese
runde besteht zumindest zu mindestens 90
prozent aus dabel kills das freut nicht
dafür stehe ich mit meinem namen
kennst du kennst ja ich kann nicht von
wem ihr stell ich weiß nicht ob haye ist
es nicht von dieser hab hier von der
firma ich sagt auch hip frist für
streams frist habe ich gewusst habe
okay aber erholen er hat es noch nicht
ganz geschafft dass hinter dem einer ist
glaube ich das könnte sagten händler
so leute die haben sie gerade gar nicht
angegriffen die leute hier die zwei
berliner auf den sie gehen halt auf den
premium folgt nur die prämie jetzt okay
der brauch noch ein hit und heraus dann
hab ich mal erleben einer hinter dir ist
eine ich weiß ich weiß ich habe einen
halben von hans nähen vor dir zu
überwältigen kriegst regeneration dann
machen können okay der hat ja hatten
eine propheten kräfte eingesetzt ja und
er läuft durch die wand bio genau motto
fox mit dem los alter what the [ __ ]
alter der läuft einfach durch die wand
und gib mir eine milliarde hitze in
einer millisekunde
als ich mein letztes leben leute was
euch gegen den machen alter aber ich war
ich glaub ich glaube ich dass sex hatte
ehrlich gesagt es ist ein
man könne nicht öffnen einfach nur
connection wegziehen er ist wieder mit
ist wieder ein gartenschlauch mit
jetzt aber noch ein lüfter down sein
ich würde fast so weit geht meine andere
dafür einen bogen dafür einsetzen und
holt und freund und u
okay das sind jetzt drei leute die sich
da vielleicht sandwiches und ich hatte
auch die falsche sachen genommen über
mittel aus fleisch
ich habe den ich muss noch eine raus
geflogen an dieser stelle gerade eben
meine kopfhörer sind scheiß aus leute am
sorry but i can't change kommen jetzt
hier einfach die musik
okay ein erstes war mein kirchlicher
theorie denn er hat keine region der es
richtig los ohne protest richtig laut
der kollege angeschlagenen angel von
hinten kommt noch einer
also aufpassen mit der andere hätte ich
ihn jetzt runter gar nicht nur gelacht
er läuft oder die achtung jetzt von
hinten kommt der andere bekommt der
andere
ich nehme ich immer schnell dschasira
ist nah ist raum ist der steht genau
dahinter steht genau erkannt uns nicht
aber er greift er greift einfach nicht
an
ich sehe nicht sehen aber er greift
nicht ein junge plötzlich gerade so
holen können aber du weißt es nicht
august an vielleicht siehst es diese
aufnahme schöne grüße und sicher prophet
ich glaube doch der weiß dass der kann
auch in die zukunft sehen
leider keine pfeile bekommen heißt jetzt
rom erstmals um die kanzel verdient du
es nie gewalt
hause einfach runter ganz ehrlich button
hat nichts anderes verdient als er hat
zwei leben und ich mit meinen letzten
leben macht hier die anschaltung
anzugreifen dann hat es nicht anders
verdient und links rechts kombination
von ihm und es weg und arena heißt es
leute die zweistellige zahl im
deathmatch steht wunderbar logo ist und
in der beschreibung verlinkt lassen
daumen auch um namen sich gefallen hat
wir sehen uns bald wieder die abreise
morgen haut rein macht